the Golden State Warriors a lot of
people are saying they've got problems
because Kevin Durant possibly will not
play in Game six but the guy who was
there last night who saw it who was
there in the Oracle Arena is the
Athletics Tim cow akame and he joins the
Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison filling in
for rich so Tim before I even get there
I just want to start with when Kevin
Durant goes down with that injury last
night just give me the mood of the
Oracle one of the loudest arenas and all
of the NBA just give me the mood when
Kevin Durant and walks to the locker
room well remember that they had a
20-point lead in the in the first half
that they had kicked away at the end of
the first half and then going into third
quarter so there was already uneasiness
there was already you know the Lord are
not playing well they've given up
playoff leads before you know playoff
record 30 one-point lead they blew to
the Clippers early in that series so
there was definitely an easiness there
was you know the players you could tell
they salted you could tell the crowd
salt it though there was definitely you
know a weird mood and then when Durant
makes his jumper to only put him up
three you know they were up 20 if he
puts them up three and then look like a
non-contact injury limping you know in
everybody's heads it was a killers tear
it could be a killer Sarah was the
players admitted it and he permitted it
I would say I didn't think so just
because you normally can't even put any
weight on it and and he was lifting on I
didn't know but you could tell it was
gonna be out for a while alright who you
could tell me what I'm gonna be back in
that game and maybe not for the rest of
the series we'll see and if they lose
this game it might all be over I think
that he was hitting everybody the
enormity of that game that series that
postseason and the Kevin Durant era
maybe the entire Warriors dynasty that
was all in everybody's head what does it
mean for free agency what does it mean
for the continuation of this run that
was in there it still in the air all
right I mean know clearly if you're not
playing game six by the way he's not
playing game six so if they had lost it
yesterday they would be going to Houston
down 3-2 without Kevin Durant playing on
their guys for
five minutes the main guy's looking five
minutes in this game it would be very
close to being over he was he had them
if he managed when that one yes and went
Game seven probably without Kevin Durant
that that was I think a kind of a
galvanizing moment for the team without
him I mean I don't obviously they're not
better when he's hurt but this team has
rally before this team has been in a lot
of interesting moments it's down 3-1
there to Oklahoma City and what's
current problem playing against Kevin
Durant in rally when you got a feeling
of that that that rallying moment the
lawyers being back to who they were
before during and I don't know how long
they can sustain it but it just stopped
all that kind of search through them in
in about a 15 minute period then we
heard that Durant wasn't it wasn't a
torn Achilles reach the Warriors
announced that it was a calf strain we
will hear about the full extent of it
probably later today but the players
didn't know though they're playing just
because they got to win this game and
then they'll find out about Durant it
was a lot to go through for an arena or
the players or team management and for
the viewer I'm sure to all in about an
hour 90 minutes maybe a little bit
longer and they pulled it out they
pulled this one out we'll see what
happens in the next few one of the great
follow us on twitter at tim cow akame
he's editor in chief for the athletic SF
joined the Rich Eisen show Kirk Morrison
here filling in for rich but Tim you got
a chance to catch up with Steve Kerr
late last night he had a couple tweets
just kind of talking about how Steve
Kerr is going to have to kind of go
about now being without Kevin Durant
he's basically saying he's doubtful for
game 6 we still don't know about game 7
but from your interactions with Steve
Kerr how do the Warriors I guess feel
about this Kevin Durant injury is this
something that they can say he's
possibly coming back or they're still
awaiting the MRI yeah the way they are
but no Kevin is not playing game 6 is
the Steve kind of was meandering around
that the thing you know he's likely not
playing game six and he's five said it
looks like we don't need to be tricky
here he's not playing game six I think
it's extreme like he doesn't even get on
the plane you know that you've got an
injury
that why even put him on the plane to
get him out there and then have to get
him put them right back on the plane to
fly back when you just beginning
treatment and be ready for you to a game
7 on Sunday or a game 1 on Sunday or or
Tuesday
he's not playing game 6 I think it's
very unlikely that he will play game 7
if there's a game seven or if there's a
game one on Sunday
you just don't bounce back from a quad
injury like that we're gonna go throw
them out there and go play 40 minutes
again that's not happening so they've
got to come up with some minutes you
know they've got a lot of minutes that's
45 incredibly important minutes there
that Kevin Durant was giving them that
they're gonna have to find and they got
an incredible fourth quarter Kevon
Looney yesterday incredibly necessary
now they're gonna get that for the rest
of the series I don't think that level
don't get they'll have to increase in
minutes um but then they're gonna have
to put some guys who have not been the
rotation to play some minutes and it'll
be on the road with Houston's back
against the wall gonna be tough but I
think Jones repco who played us you know
he was the first sub in for Durant all
right he was first kind of extra guy and
when they needed somebody hit a three
but then didn't look good after that but
he will have to get some minutes I think
Andrew Bogut may be back in there maybe
matched him with capela he's been taken
out of Syria just because of the
switching and truck I can't get him out
on the three-point line but it's
Capella's on there maybe bogus and can
play some minutes they're gonna need
more than that it's going to be Lanham
they've been losing players obviously
lost the market cousins in the first
round they lose durant now you started
there not a deep team anyway they're
praying that shaun livingston can give
them the important minutes he was not
bad last night he's been bad at other
nights this is a this is a battle of
attrition and like it was last year
you know lawyers lose Andre Goodall in
Game three the rest of series the
rockets falling game by for the rest of
series this is what happens when good
teams are going hard at each other
neither one of them is very deep they're
just gonna have to find something and I
can see Kerr maybe not pushing his guy
his man guys real real hard tomorrow
because what you don't want is to have
Steph Curry play 46 minutes play 46
frame on 47 and lose and then they're
beat to hell and you still got to come
back and fly and play game seven on
they maybe you're just retry out from
the guy on tomorrow play play your main
guy's 40 42 and then if you don't win
you police are not exhausted going into
Game seven and maybe you make the
Rockets play hard and for another 45 min
PJ Tucker another 45 and Chris Paul ot 2
and maybe you win the battle over the
long haul this is a this is a huge huge
epic moment for both franchises and how
they play it tomorrow it's going to be
very interesting to watch
the inner in chief or the athletic SF
Tim Cal comic joining the Rich Eisen
show Kirk Morrison here filling in for
Rich but you mentioned it was the return
of the splash brothers right in that
fourth quarter you know usually I know
Steph usually sits in the going into a
fourth quarter but yet this time
obviously Steve Kerr had to play him and
I thought Steph I thought clay and you
mentioned come on Looney I thought was
the MVP of last night's game they were
fantastic but like to your point is
there a minutes possible restriction in
Game six knowing you still have game
seven in your building you think would
Steve Kerr in the Warriors yeah I mean
it's got to be logic if they're up to in
the fourth quarter maybe your gun for
and you try to get that you know avoid
that game seven right
I think her will play it yeah I don't
think it's gonna play it like you did
lucky that game was mandatory you
couldn't lose at home you know in a tie
game going into the fourth which it was
Durant just hobbled off you had to win
that game so he had to press every
button and parry started before but she
normally doesn't he in clay played the
entire fourth quarter which curve almost
always tries to avoid maybe with Durant
he will do that once or twice but again
you know it's the minute count that
probably contributed to that injury form
so you've got to play it somewhat
logically and I would say you know
they're not going 44 or 45 with with
Kareem clay if they're say they're
behind there they're going to fourth
down five and you don't push it if you
her close who knows right it's the
moment that it will dictate it but yeah
they're gonna play the way they played
in the fourth quarter that switches back
to 2015-2016 which is the curry
pick-and-roll at the top and let him go
and
aggressive and you know he make every
shot in the fourth quarter but he looked
much more in rhythm he looked much more
this is the ball in his hands and let me
decide and they are better with him
their aunt out there they are a great
team giver grant out there but this is
kind of muscle memory for them and it's
that joyful basketball it could blow up
you know in Game six it could be
terrible it could be great but it wasn't
like their 100 women how do we play
again without Kevin Durant so they they
knew it's Steph Curry with ball of hands
creating and finishing and shoot and you
know flip take and roll and trying to
beat the big guy on the switch and
firing for 35 they will keep doing this
and we will see again the reason why
they got Kevin her answers are better
with Kevin Durant
yeah but it was fascinating to watch
them kind of pull that out against an
old rival and it explode through Oracle
Arena you know what used to sire too
hard look like it was dragging there in
the fourth quarter I understand he's
carrying an incredible load he's having
to play defense in this series Kirk by
the way and he yes right that wears you
down so you know it isn't just the
Warriors you've got a minute's worry
you're looking at PJ Tucker who's barely
coming out of the game James Harden
barely come out of the game this is good
they're going to be some really
exhausted superstars tomorrow and if
Houston wins on Sunday you know I don't
know what they're all gonna be like for
the next series but I mean they are they
are a dear and empty tank for this
series but that's what the playoffs are
about you don't want it to you want to
see these guys challenge and they are
challenging each other no questions
you've got about 30 more seconds left
here with Tim Couch comedy editor in
chief of the athletic SF and look these
were my thoughts last night Tim and kind
of just let me know what you think I
feel like the Warriors are in a
lose-lose situation okay is that if they
lose the next two games it's because
they didn't have Kevin Durant and we
know his situation in the summer
possibly being able to leave and free
agency if they win a game six or game
seven they win without Kevin Durant and
is like oh we can still win without him
even if he goes in free agency so to me
it's like a lose-lose situation for
whatever the
come maybe with Kevin Durant yeah I
think Kevin Durant's leaving anyway I
think think that too
I'm not saying it's a done deal who
knows you could he could make any kind
of decision but you can't have that be a
factor and whether you want to win a
game or not you win it however you can
and that's what they've kind of tried to
do this season they're removing the
Durant's situation as much as they can
from what the addition will go in and
I've called the grand compromise they're
not gonna be mad at Kevin if he leaves
they've told him this play your best
basketball which he clearly has done in
the playoffs and they see what comes at
the end of it nobody's mad to each other
no I'm not saying that's gonna happen
but that's the compromise so you can't
be part of like you know it doesn't
matter because Kevin might leave so so
what no you got to play it the way you
play it and he makes a decision
independent of all that you try to win
the championship you don't gain anything
by not one of the championship and then
having everybody feel slightly better
about it possibly who cares win a
championship you deal with everything
after that there is no other reason to
do anything else and because Kevin
Durant was making it as a mine based on
a thousand things you gotta win a
championship and see what comes out for
that if they can appreciate the time as
always Tim have a good one I recur
contempt you yeah that was Tim Cole call
me the editor-in-chief of the Athletics
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app